Mira tu teléfono móvil por un momento.
SI pudieras abrir la carcasa, descubrirías
algo parecido a esto: montones de microchips,
pequeños transistores y circuitos.
Pues bien, para fabricar todo esto, hace falta
un elemento muy concreto, el TANTALIO ¿Y
de dónde viene este tantalio?
Pues, principalmente, de un país: La República
Democrática del CONGO.
Uno de los países más pobres del mundo.
Es imposible estimar la cantidad de gente
que ha muerto para fabricar el móvil que
tienes en tus manos.
El tantalio es uno de los materiales más
demandados del mundo.
Y el Congo es el país con las mayores reservas.
Podría ser una enorme fuente de riqueza para
este país.
Un país que, además, tiene muchos otros
recursos naturales.
Sin embargo, el Congo es uno de los países
más pobres y más violentos del mundo.
Y, creedme, su historia es demasiado compleja
como para explicarla con un artículo clickbait
de esos que te encuentras en Twitter de vez
en cuando ¿Por qué es pobre el Congo?
En este vídeo te lo vamos a contar.
El Congo es un país del que sólo has oído
hablar cuando viste la película “Gorilas
en la niebla”.
Es curioso, porque, por un lado, nuestra cultura
popular está llena de referencias al Congo.
Por el otro, apenas sabemos nada de su política…
Hablamos de uno de los países más grandes
del mundo, con más de 80 millones de habitantes.
Para que os hagáis una idea, toda Europa
occidental cabría en este país.
Seguro que todos habéis leído alguna vez
“Tintin en el Congo” y, de hecho, en Español
de España, todavía decimos que “esto cuesta
un Congo” cuando algo es muy caro.
¡Y no es para menos!
El Congo tiene una auténtica fortuna en recursos
naturales: caucho, minas de oro, de cobalto
y, por supuesto, de coltán, que es el mineral
de donde se saca el tantalio.
Así que, sin saberlo, todos tenemos productos
congoleños en nuestra casa.
Muchos diríais ¡El Congo está bendecido
por los recursos naturales!
Pues es justo lo contrario.
Todo este oro, cobalto y tantalio es, precisamente
la maldición del Congo.
Porque sí, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
el Congo es uno de los países más pobres
del mundo.
Y hablamos de la llamada pobreza absoluta.
La mayor parte de la población vive con menos
de un dólar al día.
Las hambrunas son la tónica habitual.
Y las guerrillas son tan normales en este
país, que ni siquiera se habla de ellas en
los telediarios.
Pero todo esto ya lo sabéis.
La pregunta es ¿Por qué?
Y la respuesta es que el Congo es un catálogo
de todas las cosas malas que puede tener un
país: guerras, malos gobiernos, corrupción
a todos los niveles y, por supuesto, colonialismo.
Imaginaos todos estos factores a escala nachovidaliana
y tendréis una buena radiografía de lo que
es el Congo.
Bueno pues ya está ¿no?
Ya sabemos por qué el Congo es tan pobre…
fin del tema ¡Por favor!
¡Esto es VisualPolitik!
El caso del Congo es único en la historia.
Ni siquiera lo podemos comparar con otros
países africanos.
Y por eso, es una historia tan catastrófica
como fascinante.
Y, si conocéis VisualPolitik, ya sabéis
que os vamos a contar todos los detalles.
Incluidos los resultados de sus últimas elecciones.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué el Congo
es tan pobre?
¿Por qué decimos que sus recursos naturales
son su maldición?
¿Puede cambiar las cosas su nuevo presidente?
Hoy, vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes… vamos a ver un poco de historia.
CÓMO PRIVATIZAR UN PAÍS
En el año 1877, el rey Leopoldo II de Bélgica
compró el Congo.
Así, tal cual.
Cuando hablamos de los procesos de colonización,
normalmente nos referimos a que un país conquista
otro país ¿Verdad?
Pues aquí viene la primera gran diferencia.
Hasta la fecha, lo que hoy conocemos como
el Congo era un territorio poblado por distintas
tribus.
Un territorio con muchísimo potencial para
plantar caucho.
Así que, cuando el rey Leopoldo II descubrió
todas estas oportunidades de negocio, se le
puso el símbolo del dólar en los ojos y
dijo “¿Para qué voy a colonizar este país…
si lo puedo comprar?”.
Eran otros tiempos.
Por aquel momento, las potencias europeas
entendían que podían hacer y deshacer en
África sin pedir permiso a nadie.
Por un lado, era una fuente de riqueza.
Por el otro, entendían que la colonización
era una forma de solidaridad.
Una forma de exportar los valores y la civilización
europea a una tierra de barbarie.
Y por eso, Leopoldo II creó en Bruselas la
Asociación Internacional Africana.
Un organismo, presidido por él, que le permitía
ir al Congo y establecer sus propias fábricas
y plantaciones de caucho.
Como los congoleños no entendían lo que
era la propiedad privada, Leopoldo II se proclamó
el dueño de todo el territorio.
Algo así como el que se compra unos terrenos
en otro país… pero sin ningún tipo de
contrato.
Por supuesto, para legitimar este saqueo,
Leopoldo II, que no dejaba de ser el rey de
un país tan respetable como Bélgica, decía
que iba a convertir el llamado “estado libre
del Congo” en un auténtico remanso de paz
y buenas costumbres…
“El Estado libre del Congo es un caso único.
No tiene nada que esconder, no tiene secretos
y sólo está agradecido a su fundador”
–Leopoldo II, Rey de Bélgica
La realidad era muy distinta.
Leopoldo II quería extraer el mayor caucho
posible.
En aquel momento se empezaban a fabricar los
primeros neumáticos, así que la demanda
de caucho no paraba de crecer.
Por eso, esclavizó a la población y les
fijó cuotas de producción imposibles.
Si uno de estos congoleños no llegaba a esos
objetivos… ¡Se le cortaba la mano!
Así es como comenzó uno de los mayores genocidios
de la historia, comparable, en términos relativos,
con la revolución cultural de Mao.
Tanto es así que incluso otras potencias
colonizadoras como Reino Unido llegaron a
denunciar al rey Leopoldo II por sus atrocidades.
Tras su muerte, Leopoldo II legó su propiedad
al estado belga, y así es como el Congo se
convirtió en una colonia belga.
El gobierno belga fue algo más compasivo
con su nueva colonia.
Al menos, cesaron las ejecuciones y torturas
masivas.
Pero los congoleños mantuvieron sus condiciones
de trabajo esclavas.
Veréis, el colonialismo es una de las prácticas
más lamentables de la historia.
Pero si hay una potencia colonizadora que
ha destacado por su brutalidad, esa es Bélgica.
Y si queréis indignaros más todavía, os
diré que, a día de hoy, Bruselas todavía
mantiene calles, edificios y monumentos en
honor al rey Leopoldo II.
Pero eso es otra historia.
Lo cierto es que en el año 1960, el Congo
se independiza de Bélgica.
Pero las cosas no fueron mejores para este
país.
Su primer presidente, LUMUMBA, quería alejarse
al máximo posible de sus ex colonizadores.
Y por eso, tanto Bélgica como Francia apoyaron
toda clase de revueltas. 5 años más tarde,
Lumumba era ejecutado.
Y así es como empezó la dictadura de MOBUTU
SESE SEKO y el país pasó a llamarse ZAIRE.
Mobutu fue uno de los dictadores más sanguinarios
de la historia.
Sin embargo, como solemos decir en VisualPolitik,
Mobutu era un hijo de puta… ¡Pero era NUESTRO
hijo de puta!
En tiempos de la guerra fría, el Congo se
mantuvo aliado de Estados Unidos y el mundo
libre.
Así que no faltaba dinero para financiar
a su ejército.
Pero las cosas cambiaron en los años 90.
Sin una Unión Soviética de la que tener
miedo, Estados Unidos dejó de apoyar a Mobutu.
Y todos esos grupos a los que había estado
reprimiendo se rebelaron contra él.
Así es como comenzó la primera guerra civil
congoleña y el país volvió a llamarse como
ahora.
Esta guerra civil dio paso a la segunda guerra
civil congoleña.
Para que os hagáis una idea, esta segunda
guerra civil congoleña está calificada como
el conflicto más sangriento después de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Más de 5 millones de muertos, millones de
mutilados y toda clase de atrocidades.
Pero… ¿sabéis que es lo peor?
Que la violencia todavía no ha terminado.
En 2003, se dio por terminada la guerra.
Desde entonces JOSEPH KABILA ha intentado
ser el dictador que domina el país con mano
de hierro.
Pero, seamos honestos, por muy autoritario
y corrupto que sea Kabila, es imposible controlar
este país.
Por todas partes encontramos guerrillas, incursiones
de países vecinos y señores de la guerra.
Sobretodo en el este.
Pero… ¿Cómo es posible que en un país
tan pobre, haya tantos grupos armados?
¿De dónde sacan el dinero?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA FIEBRE DEL COLTÁN
¿Os acordáis del famoso Nokia 6110?
Salió al mercado a finales de los 90 y fue
uno de los primeros teléfonos móviles de
consumo masivo.
De repente, todo el mundo tenía un teléfono
móvil.
Y eso significa que hacía más y más tantalio
para producirlos.
Hasta la fecha, el principal productor de
tantalio era Australia ¿El problema?
Pues que conseguir este elemento era más
caro de lo que parece.
Veréis, es casi imposible encontrar elementos
químicos puros en la naturaleza.
En este caso, la mina australiana tenía unas
rocas de donde, tras un proceso químico complejísimo,
podías sacar un poquito de tantalio.
Sin embargo, hay una forma más sencilla de
obtenerlo.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik… hablamos del
COLTÁN.
El coltán es una roca con enormes proporciones
de tantalio.
Y el refinado de estas rocas es muy barato.
¿Y a que no adivináis dónde están las
mayores reservas de coltán del mundo?
Exacto, en el este del Congo.
Básicamente, el Congo es algo así como la
Arabia Saudita del Coltán.
Hay mucho, es fácil de conseguir y fácil
de refinar.
De hecho, ni siquiera hace falta tecnología
punta.
Basta con un pico y una pala para sacar tantas
rocas de coltán como si no hubiera mañana.
Y por eso, miles de congoleños se lanzaron
a la caza del coltán ¡Pero esperad un momento
porque esto es sólo el principio!
¿Os acordáis de la crisis financiera de
2008?
Pues también tuvo algunas consecuencias en
Australia…
GAM cierra la mina de tantalio de Wodgina
Esta mina era la principal productora del
mundo.
Así que su cierre supuso un subidón en los
precios del tantalio.
Es difícil estimar el precio de mercado porque,
a diferencia del petróleo, no hay índices
públicos que muestren la cotización.
Pero según algunas consultoras, hablamos
de duplicar su valor de un año para otro
¿Y qué consecuencias tuvo esto para el Congo?
¡Exacto!
La fiebre del coltán.
De repente, todo el mundo estaba dispuesto
a jugarse la vida por conseguir unas rocas.
Sobretodo los señores de la guerra.
Es decir, que todas estas guerrillas se financiaban
con la venta de rocas de coltán.
Dicho de otra forma: a más tantalio, más
violencia.
Hablamos de tal masacre, que incluso Estados
Unidos tuvo que poner cartas en el asunto.
La propuesta Dodd-Frank se convierte en ley
Básicamente, esta ley era un texto super
extenso con medidas para proteger a los consumidores.
Una de las partes se refería a los llamados
“minerales conflictivos”.
Y uno de ellos era el tantalio.
Según esta ley, las empresas que usan tantalio
tienen que saber de dónde viene exactamente.
De esta forma, evitarían comprarlo a señores
de la guerra ¿El problema?
Que en un país como el Congo es casi imposible
controlar la trazabilidad de un mineral.
Sobretodo, teniendo en cuenta que apenas hay
empresas mineras.
Hablamos de gente normal, que se lanza al
campo a recoger rocas y se las venden a un
señor, que se lo vende a otro señor… y
al final termina en un teléfono móvil.
En muchos casos, hay mineros ruandeses que
cruzan la frontera, explotan las minas y,
después, se marchan de vuelta a Ruanda para
procesarlo.
Como sabéis, Ruanda es un país que está
creciendo muchísimo últimamente y que ofrece
muchísima más seguridad, tanto física como
jurídica, que el Congo.
Y si no lo sabéis, aquí tenéis un vídeo
donde os lo contamos.
Es más, si os interesa conocer a fondo todos
estos temas… ¡Suscribíos a VisualPolitik,
y dadle a la campanita YA para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones!
Pero volviendo al Congo… muchos os preguntaréis
que, siendo tan rentable ¿Por qué no hay
grandes empresas en el Congo?
¿No hay incentivos para extraer minerales
en masa?
Pues lo cierto es que no ¿Queréis un ejemplo?
¡Pues aquí lo tenéis!
La mayor minera de coltán del Congo reanuda
su actividad tras bajar su producción a la
mitad
En este caso, Bisunzu es una de las pocas
mineras que hay en el Congo.
La creó un senador congoleño que quería
industrializar la minería.
En lugar de extraer el coltán jugándose
la vida, Bisunzu quiere usar máquinas.
De esta forma, pueden mejorar la seguridad
de los trabajadores y extraer mucho más mineral
¿El problema?
Primero que todas estas máquinas son caras.
Y el dinero escasea en un país como el congo.
Hablamos de inversiones muy caras que requieren
estabilidad jurídica.
Pero entonces es cuando llegan los políticos
corruptos.
Y si tu problema no es la corrupción, entonces
llegan las guerrillas a robarte el coltán
o atacar tus fábricas ¿Conclusión?
Casi ninguna empresa está dispuesta a invertir
y las que lo hacen, tienen que parar la producción
cada dos por tres.
Y aquí es donde llegamos al círculo vicioso
del coltán.
Cuanta más demanda existe, más incentivos
hay para que los señores de la guerra lo
quieran explotar.
Y cuantos más señores de la guerra explotan
el coltán, menos incentivos hay para crear
una industria que de trabajos de calidad y
apoye el país.
Todo esto explica que, pese a que, tanto el
Congo como los países vecinos producen la
mitad del tantalio que se consume en el mundo,
el PIB del Congo apenas ha crecido en las
últimas décadas.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Hay alguna oportunidad
para que cambien las cosas?
Pues… puede que sí y puede que no.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL GRAN FRAUDE
¿Recordáis a Joseph Kabila?
¿El dictador del Congo?
Pues bien, en el año 2018 dejó su cargo
y se convocó elecciones.
En realidad, según la constitución congoleña,
tendría que haberlo hecho mucho antes.
Pero ya sabéis como son los dictadores.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, las elecciones
de 2018 tenían más trampas que una escopeta
de feria.
Las provincias más contrarias a Kabila sólo
tenían uno o dos colegios electorales.
Y el voto se hacia a través de unas tablets
que nadie sabia manejar.
Vamos, que ningún observador internacional
aceptaba este proceso.
El Congo a la Unión Europea: ocúpate de
tus asuntos
Están a punto de celebrar unas elecciones
que han sido pospuestas por dos años y el
país ha echado al embajador de la Unión
Europea
Pues bien, en estas elecciones había tres
candidatos importantes: RAMAZONI, que era
el sucesor de Kabila, FAYULU, que era el opositor
y TSHISEKEDI, que era el que tenía menos
posibilidades.
Pues bien ¿A que no adivináis quien ganó?
Pues no, no ganó Ramazoni.
Ganó Tshisekedi.
Y aquí es donde surge el debate.
Porque según todas las organizaciones que
han observado las elecciones, incluida la
Iglesia católica, el proceso no ha podido
ser más sucio.
Según muchos analistas, Kabila sabe que nadie
iba a aceptar que ganara su sucesor.
Así que ha dado la victoria a un opositor
moderado, que al menos le permitirá mantener
su fortuna.
No olvidéis que, tras años de dictadura
hiper corrupta, Kabila es millonario.
Sin embargo, Donald Trump apoya a Tshisekedi,
aunque sólo sea por garantizar un gobierno
mínimamente estable para el Congo.
Y la pregunta es ¿Pueden cambiar las cosas
con este nuevo presidente?
Pues lo cierto es que oportunidades no le
faltan.
Litio y Tantalio, la nueva producción australiana
de Pilbara
Básicamente, los australianos han descubierto
un nuevo modo para producir tantalio de forma
barata.
Y eso significa que han reabierto su mina
¿Y esto qué puede significar?
Pues… menos sed de coltán para los congoleños,
menos dinero para las guerrillas y más incentivos
para crear empresas éticas y con industria.
Por otra parte, Ruanda, el país vecino, ya
está desarrollando su propia industria de
refinería del coltán.
En 2018, crearon una enorme factoría para
producir tantalio.
Incluso están empezando a experimentar con
la tecnología blockchain para poder estudiar
la trazabilidad del tantalio.
Es decir, que todo el mundo pueda saber cómo
y de dónde viene el mineral que compra.
Pues bien, el nuevo gobierno congoleño tiene
ahora la oportunidad de asociarse con sus
vecinos para crear una industria del coltán
que genere empleos y riqueza.
Pero ahora la pregunta es ¿Están dispuestos
a hacerlo?
¿De verdad este nuevo presidente congoleño
va a acabar con la corrupción reinante para
sacar a su país de la pobreza?
¿O seguiremos viendo como el Congo se empobrece
día tras día… pese a tener tantos recursos
naturales?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y antes de terminar, tengo que darle las gracias
a SUZANE, de ROSKILL, por ayudarme con la
investigación.
Roskill es una de las principales consultorías
de minería del mundo.
Y han sido muy amables con nosotros contestando
todas nuestras preguntas y facilitándonos
un montón de información que, de otro modo,
habría sido imposible de conseguir.
Y también gracias a MARTI, de CdeCiencia,
que me ha ayudado un montón para entender
el mundo de las rocas, el tantalo y el coltán.
CdeCiencia es uno de los mejores canales de
ciencia de todo YouTube así que, si no lo
conocéis, deberíais echarlo un vistazo.
Como siempre, si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.